this video is brought to you by wix
street art has captured the world's
attention in recent years
developing its very own graffiti
industrial complex
skater kid shepard fairy parlayed his
80s sticker street art into a guerrilla
marketing company
he's now worth millions 90s graffiti
artist retina
turned his scribbles into a cool
multi-million dollars worth of fine art
but the coca-cola of this market
undoubtedly is
banksy the anonymous dude with that
voice there's probably a mall in there
somewhere
the guy built a fake depressing disney
world made a
debatably fake amusing documentary and
shred his painting
right after it sold for massive amounts
of money he also bought a painting at a
thrift shop for fifty dollars painted
hitler into it and sold it for charity
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
people tend to think that banksy is
either some [ __ ] worthy only of
parody
that's what i told lady gaga no you text
me she texted me
or that he's an artistic genius the real
question is
what is banksy trying to do with his art
and is his work achieving its intended
goal
we're going to find out in this
wisecrack edition on banksy
deep or dumb but before we get to it a
message from me
mark aka garrick's wormy lloyd how about
this video's sponsor wix
as an actor in la it can be very hard to
set yourself apart which is why i
decided to use wix to make a
professional website that i can
shamelessly send out to hollywood
producers as you can see here i went on
there and i just told them that i never
created a website before and it walked
me through the process step by step
within minutes i was uploading all my
photos all my videos and some earthling
cinema highlights it was super easy
so if you want to step up your
professional game head to wix.com
wisecrack
or click the link in the video
description garrick's out
arguably the world's most famous street
artist banksy is a professional
prankster best known for making
satirical graffiti
that frequently depicts children rats
and repurposed iconography
typically the images will be accompanied
by a slogan and the various facets will
combine to form
some sort of anti-war anti-capitalist or
anti-establishment message
of course banksy isn't your typical
street artist even by art world
standards
he's made a lot of money his estimated
worth is over 20 million dollars what's
more his art is no longer typical street
art
it's frequently safeguarded with
plexiglass or removed from buildings
entirely to be protected for posterity
cool but
is it deep or dumb argument 1 yes banksy
is v smart the latest iteration of a
long line of smart art people doing
smart art things because art is often
appraised and understood by its relation
to other art we need to look back
to data-ism thought-ism was a form of
art that began in world war one as a
means of rejecting capitalism and
ridiculing the absurdity of modern life
it manifested as a form of protest art
and one of its central practitioners was
marcel duchamp
who famously coined the term anti-art to
describe work that challenged our
preconceived definitions of what
art should be like when he submitted a
urinal on a pedestal titled fountain for
an exhibition in new york
for this he used the term ready-made to
mean an already produced or found
object that is repurposed as art he
chose mass-produced commercial objects
typically ones that served a utilitarian
purpose
like say a urinal as he said you have to
approach the object
as if you had no aesthetic emotion the
choice of readymades is always based on
visual indifference
duchamp was hoping that by exhibiting
something that was explicitly
not art literally anti-art he could
ironically call into question where our
concept of art starts and ends
while also arguing that anything even a
urinal could be art
of his ready-made he also said i don't
attach any value i mean commercial value
or even artistic value to it
so additionally by displaying art that
is for practical purposes
worthless he's perhaps questioning why
we even value art in the first place
cool for duchamp the creative act of art
was not the sole endeavor
of the artist but a sort of
collaboration with the spectator
who contributes to the creative act by
deciphering and interpreting it
with duchamp the reaction of his
audience was an essential part of the
artwork itself
while duchamp never admitted exactly
what he hoped people's reactions would
be to his pedestal piss pot
he does seem to have expressed regret at
how people actually reacted
later in life he bemoaned that you can
make people swallow anything
that's what happened with fountain
duchamp seems to be saying that in
attempting to challenge the entire
concept of art
he ended up merely expanding the range
of what kinds of images and objects
people would choose to commodify and
revere
basically duchamp wanted to make you
scrunch up your nose and picture your
art covered in piss
as a productive means of challenging
conventional notions of what art should
or shouldn't be but instead of being
grossed out people were like sweet
can i buy this used urinal for 20
million dollars please
which brings us to banksy who like
duchamp critiques the pretentiousness of
the art world
banksy argues that art is not like other
culture because its success is not made
by its audience
the public fill concert halls and
cinemas every day we read novels by the
millions and by records by the billions
we the people affect the making and
quality of most of our culture
but not our art like duchamp banksy
wants to
degrade the perceived snobbishness of
the art world by a
using the everyday streets as his canvas
and b
using familiar simple images that are
universally accessible
regardless of whether you just wrote
your dissertation on early russian
modernism
furthermore banksy's work is all about
criticizing capitalism and consumerism
ironically the popularity of his work
triggers rabid consumerism being
physically removed from buildings to be
sold in auctions on the art market
or protected from the elements with
plexiglas arguably banksy's most
daughter moments came this past october
when his painting grew with balloon
self-destructed immediately after being
sold for just over a million pounds
banksy was following a specific
tradition of auto-destructive art
invented by artist gustav metzger in the
early 1960s
metzger famously used acid to paint a
white nylon sheet
in the process destroying it
auto-destructive art emphasized the
audience's participation in the work
with artists typically destroying their
work in a public space
the destruction and bearing witness to
that destruction was all
part of the work but he was also
referencing the tradition of dadaism
as that ironically degrades or destroys
the bubble of the art world
and that way banksy's latest work
definitely qualifies by emphasizing the
material fragility and ease
with which art can be transformed into a
pile of strips
[Music]
even if you're not a banksy enthusiast
you can probably admit that it was
pretty punk rock
more on balloon girl later but don't
worry banksy skeptics there's plenty
here for you
argument 2 banksy is irrelevant his
audience's opinion
is all that matters according to the
theory of structuralism articulated by
scholar roland barton his earlier years
there is no foundation of meaning in an
artist's intention
rather meaning is grounded in whatever
culture and systems exist
at any given time for example the first
caveman art critic who looked at this ox
was probably like
daniel's really pushing his work to the
next level whereas we're like
oh cute finger painting bart as he wrote
in his essay death of the author
sees meaning as being anchored in the
culture surrounding art
and it's our job as cultural detectives
to figure out what the
f this means structuralism makes sense
when it comes to an artist like banksy
who purposely remains anonymous and
gives
evasive answers about his intentions by
not declaring exactly what any one piece
of art means
banksy is protecting our ability to
decide for ourselves
thus giving the audience all the
interpretive space in the world to
theorize and argue over answers we'll
never have
such as whether or not his documentary
exit through the gift shop
is fake for an example of work that
relies almost
entirely on societal context to be
understood look at banksy's kissing
coppers
in the image two male police officers
passionately kiss
this work was widely viewed as a
repudiation of homophobia
a middle finger to the ugly tradition of
the law telling people who
and how they should love however compare
kissing coppers to
now routine images of president trump
and vladimir putin engaged in various
forms of romantic intimacy
these images are clearly disparaging
suggesting that trump's perceived
subordination to putin
is embarrassing or shameful through the
metaphor of gay intimacy
in other words if banksy's anonymity is
meant smartly to give more power to the
spectator and their interpretation
is that completely ruined if half of the
people read your work in the opposite
way you
intended in the case of kissing coppers
did he set out to
mock homophobia or was he merely trying
to humiliate cops by suggesting that
these stereotypical manly men
harbor gay fantasies does this ambiguity
subvert banksy's ability to
accomplish anything or does it
unapologetically function as a mirror to
its viewer
who are free to interpret it as either
pro-gay rights or
simply homophobic does his anonymity
hinder his ability to communicate his
message
argument 3 there was never any chance
for banksy to be deep
because post-modernism for an even less
flattering angle on banksy let's look to
thomas mann's postmodernist theories
which hold that there's basically no way
for a successful artist to critique the
art market through
art why well because the second they
start making art that is recognized by
the commercial market
they have thus entered said market so
are all
successful artists sellouts would a
banksy writhing around
broke in obscurity tagging the streets
of london be
more effective than rolling in dough
banksy well it's possible
that said only rolling in dough banksy
could pull off a project
like dismaland a temporary art project
and
anti-amusement park that featured works
from 58 other artists
it sold out almost instantly with 6
million people trying to buy tickets and
crashing the site
people waited for hours to gain entry
it's been criticized as something
highbrow middle-class millennials
participated in to feel better about
themselves
arguably in setting out to critique the
self-indulgent branded fun of amusement
parks
banksy simply replicated that experience
with a snarky facade
if he set out to create an
anti-amusement park he may have simply
just
made a hipster disney world also the
project was criticized as not really
having anything to say besides
capitalism bad let's briefly jump back
to girl with a balloon here
banksy pulled off a pretty cool stunt
that gave the middle finger to all the
art snobs bidding on his work
however after the piece was shredded it
only increased its value
as leon benraman the director of modern
and contemporary art at heritage
auctions explains
it was meant to be a criticism of the
art market and
i think it's going to double the value
of the work
this is the ultimate example of the
damned if he does damned if he doesn't
conundrum of being banksy or
any other artist for that matter you'd
almost have to feel bad for the guy
if he wasn't a millionaire one last
point on this so
banksy's anti-capitalist work has been
incorporated into the very capitalist
system he dislikes
now people pay top dollar for his work
setting for 860
and retweet his art on the ad soaked
feeds of instagram
but what if this is just proof of
banksy's success
here we are at dismal land or banksy's
bethlehem hotel
or gathering around a random gas station
or a hoity-toity art auction to consume
his work
what if us voraciously partaking in this
system
the very thing he's making fun of means
that the joke
quite simply is on us on to argument 4
banksy is deep because he's a culture
jammer in the grand tradition of
situationism
the situationist international was an
organization of social revolutionaries
made up of avant-garde artists
intellectuals and political theorists
who ran around europe pulling artsy lols
from 1957 until 1972.
one of the group's favorite tactics was
the situation as prank a subversive
political prank
hoax or stunt for instance when some
situation is dressed up like monks and
gave a sermon
on easter sunday at notre dame
announcing verily i say unto you
god is dead they used a technique called
determined french for rerouting or
hijacking
which essentially means changing
something so that it means something
entirely different
than its original intention particularly
in regards to capitalist messaging
like if i write capitalism does not suck
on my store window
and you crossed out the knot now that
would be a very dumb example of
determine and nobody would be impressed
or say painting blood on the nike logo
because
you know sweatshops culture jamming
taking its influence from the situation
is tries to disrupt our environments
which are so
deeply saturated by corporate and
consumer imagery the average north
american
consumes five times more than a mexican
ten times more than a chinese person and
thirty times more than a person from
india they do so by using mainstream
language and rhetoric subversively
to critique the culture and force us to
reconsider it
we definitely see banksy interrogate
these questions
in works like slave labor which depicts
a young boy making union jack bunting
ahead of the diamond jubilee in 2013.
a pretty straightforward critique of
sweatshop labor the image was painted
on the exterior of a poundland discount
store in london
however it was removed framed and sold
in an auction for over
seven hundred thousand pounds ironically
what started as a provocative stunt
ended up being co-opted by the very
market forces banksy was critiquing
in the first place successful determined
maybe not compare his efforts to those
of the yes man
led by culture jamming duo jacques
cervan and igor vamos
operating under the mission of using
humor and trickery to highlight the
corporate takeover of society
i think barry as well as all the other
protesters are simply
in a word focused too too much on
reality and on facts and figures the yes
men made a name for themselves creating
spoof websites and posing as corporate
spokesmen
in one example they impersonated world
trade organization spokesman and pitched
the idea of using
first world waste to provide third world
food
the number one number two number three
number four number five would no longer
refer to combinations of food
but rather just uh the number of times
the product had been recycled
this function as effective culture
jamming because for one the performance
couldn't be directly commodified
though it would be memorialized in a yes
men documentary film
and it directly confronts the powerful
fully employing corporate lexicon
in service of constructing colorful
elaborate lies
that reveal stunning truths about the
full extent of corporate greed
while indicting the cold calculated
fundamentally dishonest nature of
business speak
instead we might put banksy alongside
the likes of fellow graffiti artist
shepard ferry
whose obey stickers might have once
invoked this anti-consumerist message in
the film they live
but now adorns a 44 doormat
or supreme who took the anarchist
beloved brick
an object perfect for sending through a
bank window and stamped their logo on it
for a limited edition collector's item
you can now buy one on ebay for over a
thousand dollars
radical so at the end of the day what
should you think of banksy
well whatever the hell you want
obviously you can find his art valid and
meaningful but
is it productive not really will it
incite a revolution to
overthrow capitalism definitely unlikely
is its massive popularity and high value
in the art market
necessarily at odds with its success as
anti-establishment intervention
almost certainly so what do you think is
banksy deep
dumb or somewhere in between and is art
really better when nobody knows about it
let us know in the comments and if you
want to build your own website with wix
click the link in the description and as
always peace
[Music]